scp-173 it's one of the most iconic
anomalies ever contained by the scp
foundation this next snapping site 19
celebrity is known and feared by
everyone who works at the foundation
since being contained in 1993. its nubby
concrete hands metaphorically and quite
literally stained with the blood of
countless people but this mostly
immobile oddity wasn't always a resident
of site 19 and the story of how exactly
it ended up there and more importantly
why it's far more ridiculous insane and
downright terrifying than you could ever
imagine so buckle up scp fans this is
the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of modern art ended up at the scp
foundation's largest containment site to
give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is we're gonna have to leap
forward to the year of 2045.
we know what you're thinking isn't this
a prequel how can it take place in the
future sit tight folks it'll all make
sense in the end site 91 is where we lay
our scene under the watchful eyes of
site director dr james long a senior
researcher with level 4 security
clearance the second highest at the
foundation
dr long had given decades of devotion
and his expertise to the foundation he
was a proud man who wore his life of
service to the containment cause as a
badge of honor after years of dodging
death while researching some of the most
dangerous anomalies that site 91 had to
offer he had ascended to the rank of
site director which represented the
culmination of his life's work and in
his new position of power he'd only
proved himself further running a tight
ship and reducing the number of
containment breaches across the board
nobody could say that dr long wasn't
extremely talented at his job which is
why he was so confused when he received
an email from alexandra nala an
administrative assistant working
directly for the o5 council it was the
type of email that no site director ever
wanted to receive dr long was being told
that with no input or oversight from him
the majority of site 91's anomalies were
going to be taken to an undisclosed
location for safer containment the list
contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site including
of course scp-173
this particular anomaly had been
contained at the site for 37 years after
being delivered there in 2008 dr long
had devised a perfect method to minimize
containment breaches in that time
creating a sprinkler system within the
chamber that washes away the waste
products produced by 173 reducing the
need for risky human contact but that
didn't matter despite dr long's loyalty
and efficacy in serving the scp
foundation the decision had already been
made with no chance of reversing it
according to nala the motion to remove
most of site 91's anomalies had received
unanimous approval from the o5 council
and the operations for the transfer
would be commandeered by the department
of extra universal affairs headed by
senior agent sven kish dr long was both
upset and confused he was producing some
of the best results across the entire
foundation so why were they taking away
all of his anomalies did someone on the
yo-5 council have it out for him dr long
replied to nala asking if considering
how severe the relocation operation was
going to be whether he could get more
information on where the anomalies were
being moved to and why he felt that at
the very least he was owed some answers
on this nala and her superiors didn't
feel quite the same way she replied that
dr long sadly didn't have the clearance
to know any of the operations
particulars this information was
reserved for those with level 5
clearance and members of the
multi-universal department all that dr
long needed to do was stay out of the
way and everything would be taken care
of for him but that wasn't enough for dr
long he needed to know more he needed to
understand why this seemingly random
decision had been made realizing that
nala and the o5 council were a dead end
as far as information was concerned he
instead reached out to the next best
thing senior agent sven kish the member
of the department of extra universal
affairs who was spearheading the
relocation mission dr long implored the
agent to give him extra information on
where all the site 91 anomalies were
being moved and why they were being
moved in the first place predictably he
was once again stonewalled being told
that any information regarding the
project was above his level of clearance
in a move that seemed decidedly spiteful
agent kish signed off by saying that he
looked forward to seeing dr long at site
91 and not long after that he did agent
kish along with a huge number of agents
and task force members from the multi-u
department arrived on site bearing
state-of-the-art containment equipment
an exasperated dr long wasn't able to
glean any more information from this
experience the multi-u agents were
ruthlessly efficient transferring the
lion's share of the anomalies into
temporary containment and transporting
them off-site within a few hours by the
time they were done dr long and his
staff were left with one of the most
desolate and empty containment sites on
the foundation's books here was dr long
with decades of service and climbing the
organizational ladder only to be left as
a glorified babysitter for a handful of
low priority anomalous items it all felt
like a cruel joke after several days of
nothing happening in the now incredibly
uneventful site 91 aboard dr long
reached out to a friend of his
researcher nurul shafike binte ahmad
he called by the nickname shaq to vent
his frustrations she commiserated
sharing her sympathy for his suddenly
much less exciting working conditions
but saying that at least the job should
be a little less lethal now shaq didn't
know it yet but on this particular point
she was terribly wrong dr long shared
his theory that perhaps some sites were
being consolidated so the foundation
could save money and that this would
lead to layoffs shaq essentially told
him that he was worrying too much the
reality was that dr long had some very
good reasons to be worried his problem
was that he hadn't been worrying about
the right things in foundation
containment area 179 something awful was
brewing as usual guns posted around
scp-2317
an old door containing a portal to
another world waited while foundation
staff and d-classes performed the
standard procedure 220 calabasas ritual
within they were dealing with one of the
most dangerous anomalies in the entire
universe but even then after decades of
service one can be numb to such things
suddenly without warning the door opened
and a terrified foundation researcher
tumbled out panting heavily eyes bulging
in existential horror he screamed the
words that he long hoped would never be
spoken in his or even his children's
lifetime it happened the chains have
broken the devourers free the siren
sounded and an alert spread across the
entire foundation database
scp-2317 is compromised scp-2317-k
the devourer of worlds is free if the
creature escapes area 179 an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario is basically
assured so all efforts will be taken to
make sure that the creature does not
escape at any cost and they really did
mean any cost the old wooden door of
scp-2317 splintered as an immense scaly
hand sprang forth and caught a wave of
devastation throughout the containment
chamber guards were dispatched in the
hundreds with heavy weaponry to buy some
time firing at the devourer a beast the
size of a mountain rose from the ground
staring at the terrified humans below
with its one gigantic red eye it
couldn't even feel the bullets
explosives or incendiary and laser
weaponry being used on it the monster
just shrugged it off and murdered nearly
all of its attackers with one swipe of
its claw in a final desperate act hoping
to kill or at least slow down the beast
staff at area 179 made the ultimate
sacrifice and detonated the entire
on-site nuclear arsenal the explosion
disintegrated the entire facility in an
instant and unleashed a radioactive
shock wave that carried destruction for
miles but it wasn't enough
scp-2317-k
walked out of the mushroom cloud without
a scratch on it ready to show the human
world what real destruction meant at
this point the battle was already
effectively lost but the foundation
refused to go down without a fight they
dispatched all available mobile task
forces including mobile task force new 7
hammer down a heavily armed battalion
strength task force created to combat
the biggest and most extensive threats
imaginable and it wasn't even just the
foundation true existential threats have
a way of uniting people has the goc and
even the chaos insurgency temporarily
put aside their differences to take the
fight to the devourer but would any of
it be enough barrages of cruise missiles
and icbms did nothing to halt the
devourer's assault as it rampaged
destroying towns and cities at first
then regions then whole nations swarms
of scrambled jets and helicopters were
knocked out of the sky with casual
swipes the creature bulldozed over
landscapes teeming with tanks and heavy
artillery vehicles it snapped aircraft
carriers in half as it waded from ocean
to ocean systematically destroying
everything in its path even
satellite-mounted orbital cannons and
the heavy energy weapons of mtf tau5
also known as samsara did nothing to
phase the devourer it was finally coming
to fruition the dreaded xk class end of
the world scenario and none of the
foundation's expertise advanced
technology or limitless resources could
do anything to stop it they aided in
evacuation efforts getting as many
people as they could out of harm's way
as the devourer rampaged and destroyed
but even that was doing little more than
borrowing time eventually the devourer
would destroy all of them there would be
nothing left and all dr james long could
do was watch helplessly from an almost
empty site 91 waiting for the tide of
destruction to reach him of course other
foundation employees most prominently
senior agents ven kish and the multi-u
department had other concerns all they
needed to do was archive data for
extraction the extraction to where you
ask seeing as the world seems to be at
its end here well universe 7392 epsilon
blue lima otherwise known as our
universe circa 1993 the foundation works
across the multiverse and an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario in one
universe really isn't necessarily a
problem in others on orders of the o5
council agent kish and his men are
charged with extracting data and
valuable anomalies like scp-173 from
doomed universes o5 knew that dr long's
universe universe 5643 gamma orange
delta was due for an apocalyptic visit
from the devourer of worlds any day now
that's why the multi-u team went in to
extract everything worth saving dr long
and the millions of other level 4 and
below employees of that universe's
foundation were never told of their
impending doom after all that sort of
thing could probably lead to unnecessary
stress and what they don't know won't
hurt them until of course it does in
1993 these anomalous doomed universe
scps were divided amongst our universe's
various applicable containment sites
scp-173 as you already know ended up in
site 19 but sadly for the people working
there all the actual data files on this
entries file were lost in translation so
as far as they knew 173 was little more
than a big weird statue with apparently
dangerous properties upon first placing
it in its containment chamber and
site-19 euclid wing foundation legend dr
bright unaware of just what he had here
assigned dr william moto to begin
research on the entity he recommended
that the researcher bring two d-classes
for testing when dr moto was faced with
the anomalous entities blank file he
gave a sign began to write something in
its description box move to site 19 1993
origin is as of yet unknown wasn't that
a delightful little tale now we know how
scp-170 made its way into site 19 and
what our own universe may have to look
forward to in 2045
so remember if you ever see agent sven
kish planning a transfer of anomalies
out of your site maybe consider using
some of that pto and maybe consider
putting a down payment on a nice cozy
apocalypse bunker over in iceland know
of other tales you'd like to see us
cover let us know down in the comments
below now go check out scp-001 when day
breaks and scp-1730 what happened to
site 13 the full story compilation for
more terrifying tales from the scp
foundation